un salon transformé en plateau de
télévision danseuses musiciens ou encore
photographes des artistes chinois se
sont pris au jeu de l'aventuré
télévisuelle
voilà donc nu de la culture intro 2
c'est par amour pour leur ville que
julien antoine et louis ont voulu
promouvoir la culture locale dans le
nouveau rapport qui a pas de culture et
que l'espace rien c'est pas vrai la
preuve
et puis en plus c'est vraiment le moment
parce que nous regardons du confinement
de la pandémie ce sont 7 un secteur
d'activité qui a vraiment besoin je
pense on pense tous d'un coup de main
d'une visibilité est soutenu dans le
vert avec le soutien bénévole de
professionnels du secteur le projet a pu
voir le jour sous la forme d'une
émission télé d'environ une heure elle
sera composé de tables rondes
entrecoupées par des vidéos de danse des
extraits musicaux et de spectacles pour
julie weiss était aussi l'occasion de
retrouver les sensations de la scène
déjà mais paraît de danser dans notre
salon que danser dans un studio dans
s'ouvre sur une scène et malgré tout en
fait on peut trouver des petites choses
qui qu'il nomme un petit peu et qui nous
font ressentir cet épanouissement qu'on
ressent dans une salle de danse ou dans
une salle de spectacle et même si la
crise sanitaire actuelle a été cruelle
pour le monde du spectacle elle peut
aussi être une source d'inspiration
la vidéo en question est là trois
séquences dans deux qui sont à
l'extérieur dont des grands endroits et
j'ai voulu faire la dernière séquence
qui revenait dans quelque chose de plus
clos pour peut revenir ce qu'on peut
vivre en ce moment avec le confinement
s'adapter encore et toujours au risque
parfois de se perdre
il faudrait pas non plus que les
nouvelles choses que maintenant place
viennent maintenant par exemple vraiment
une public faire des choses peut-être
les gens sont moins payés pouvais pas
car force est la norme et qu'on
s'invente tout le temps l'émission la
nuit de la culture chinoise sera diffusé
le 17 décembre à 20 heures sur la page
facebook je soutiens gien point fr
[Musique]